so there I was woke up with a heavy case
of amnesia in the middle of nowhere the
only clue to my past is Harry's name and
address inside this hat so I made my way
to the apartment and that's when I found
you and your stapler got elucidation so
you're talking Pikachu with no memories
who's addicted to caffeine I could stop
whenever I want these are just choices
another round extra shot I don't know
maybe hair got in too deep and mixed up
the wrong crowd that kind of thing you
can talk to humans and I can talk to
Pokemon and if you want to find your
pops we're gonna need you to know I
don't need a Pokemon what about a
world-class detective hey bud what are
you doing I can't do it when people are
watching that's a twist
that's very twisty
no he's barely moving don't tell him
that
oh he's on a fight quick get in front of
him stop oh no he's going down hard Tim
should have worn a helmet you know I
lived in I breathed and I became the
character I spent till the entire year
as Detective Pikachu bringing detective
Pikachu to the big screen is a privilege
that I don't take lightly every second
of my energy is spent making this
character come alive with the same
exacting standards that the most
discerning fans would have come to
expect now as many of you know I vanish
into my roles you know this is a funny
anecdote I was I was on my way to pick
up my daughters from school when I heard
that I got the role well I didn't show
up at school because detective Pikachu
he doesn't know who those two little
girls are who are they they're our
daughters he just he just left them he
doesn't have a wife you know he's a
little yellow guy there's a rhyme city
in a briar patch or something I immerse
myself completely within the world of
Pokemon I read about him I live at his
height I tried to lose 182 pounds to
match his weight until doctors
intervened I mean he didn't even change
his voice it just it just sounds like
him the point is my daughter's they may
never see their dad again but you can be
damn sure that they're looking up at
that big screen this summer and they're
gonna see detective Pikachu
pika-pika just me hey everybody it's
Charlie Ryan Reynolds drop the new
detective Pikachu trailer in that parody
video I love Blake Lively his wife
saying we're totally not going to be
seeing this film in theaters we're not
taking our children to this but I do
have a theory about the plot of the
movie I think the combining the plot of
the videogame that detective Pikachu
videogame in the plot of the original
Pokemon animated movie so we'll break it
down there's a new round of the IMAX
ticket giveaway - all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite moment from the trailer on the
video most people probably freaking out
about Mewtwo but that's really where I
think that they're roping in some of the
plot from the videogame and the original
movie because they sort of give you
enough in this trailer to put the pieces
together if you haven't played the
videogame I'll try to explain what was
going on during that but I do think that
they're changing some of the video game
plot so it won't be exactly like that
but when you see the car fly off the
road that's actually Tim's father he's
investigating this lab here where it
seems like they're cloning pokemons
illegally and where they create Mewtwo
which is also a little bit of the plot
of the first animated movie scientists
create Mewtwo Mewtwo destroys them
everything goes completely off the rails
but the plot of the videogame is a
little bit different it also involves a
lot of big Mewtwo moments the cool thing
too is if you played the video game and
you felt like the ending was really
ambiguous I do think that they're doing
the ending twist from the video game but
the movie might spell it out a little
more clearly and give them a place to go
if they want to do a sequel to this
movie because I think the whole idea is
is that if it's successful they'll make
another one when you see Tim's father's
car fly off the road you see that blast
it looks like the greninja's are
blasting him the ones that climb out of
those special tanks it's the same tank
that you see blow up in this scientists
face
that's probably Mewtwo trying to escape
but the really important thing here
though is in this main villains office
that sort of ties all these theories
together about you to in the evil
cloning so it seems like whoever he is
he's completely obsessed with collecting
rare and powerful Pokemon because you
see a statue of a legendary Pokemon back
here Dialga then you see a Palkia then
you see Arceus and a lot of people have
been going crazy about the Flareon here
but I actually think that what's going
on here is a big twist because remember
this villain looks like he's trying to
clone Mewtwo is that this is
secretly am you just using its transform
ability to make itself look like a
flareon so it makes sense that if he has
a Mew he's using its DNA to try and
clone himself Mewtwo just like the plot
of the very first Pokemon animated movie
in early theory about how they're
adapting the plot of the videogame
it as it applies to Pikachu his amnesia
and the reason why he doesn't know how
to be a normal pokémon or use his
abilities or only instinctively like he
uses his lightning-bolt ability here he
uses bolt charge but he doesn't know how
to fight when he's in the arena get me
out of here
the theory is they're pulling that
directly from the game and it also
explains why Tim can understand him but
no one else is because Pikachu's amnesia
and the disappearance of Tim's father
who was investigating this evil cloning
facility all happened around the same
place so this accident took place
simultaneously with the escape of Mewtwo
that used his psychic ability to combine
Tim's father's mind with Pikachu's that
would explain why this version of
Pikachu isn't acting like a normal
Pikachu doesn't know how to use its
normal abilities and starts to adopt the
mannerisms of Tim's father even though
it's kind of speaking with its own voice
obviously Ryan Reynolds looks nothing
like Tim's father doesn't sound like him
either
so theory is is the detective Pikachu is
an amalgam of the mind of Tim's father
combined with a normal Pikachu pokémon
that would also kind of explain a twist
where they spend the whole movie
wondering what happened to Tim's father
did he fake his own death like we don't
understand it doesn't make any sense
well that's because maybe he's been
walking around next to him this whole
time so if they did a sequel he would
still have his father with him like the
piece of him would have survived but you
still continue on with this new entity
that is detected Pokemon that sounds
like Ryan Reynolds the big parades seem
that they have in the trailer is also a
big part of the video game he is there
turning into a much bigger thing during
the movie but also in this office there
a couple big Easter eggs - the ice stone
on the desk is used to evolved ice type
Pokemon the crystal in the middle it
might be a sin o stone this one on the
right here is an old amber is just a
fossil containing the DNA of an
Aerodactyl remember this is supposed to
be the villains offices where Pikachu is
saying that's a big twist so just
imagine all these rare and legendary
Pokemon statues and memorabilia in this
guy's office just because he's so
obsessed with it but there are a whole
bunch of new Pokemon that we see during
the trailer I mean there's gonna be a
crazy number
during the film at the watch it a couple
times to catch a ball there's a bunch of
Joel ticks crawling on the telephone
wires the bartender that they have that
joke with is the Ludicolo this is
Charizard sitting next to his trainer
who has a giant tattoo of Charizard on
his chest at The Rime City Police
Station there's a whole bunch of new
ones the police officers walking in both
have growl eyes there's an evolved one
over here that's turned into an ARCA
nine the two giant go lurks are guarding
the station there's a squirtle walking
out here there's a match amp directing
traffic while this Snorlax is just
asleep in the middle of the street
there's a Pancham Pierre a Jigglypuff
and a Moga up here on top of the bus
stop a pangoro in the background there's
a sign that's designed to look like a
scraggy there's a sign of a Jolteon way
in the background here we see our first
snubbull there's another Bulbasaur
there's a really raw looking liquor
tongue the people have been talking
about on social media for the past week
or so this neon sign is they're walking
out is made to look like a knocked out
this is a more low above these other
Bulbasaur's while they're walking in the
stream here these look like [ __ ] peas and
flabébé stuff flower Pokemon just as
they're walking by so pokemon all over
the landscape here lucy has her Psyduck
and a backpack on her back here it's
also the one that explodes earlier in
the trailer here where you see this
giant explosion this seems like the
entrance to that underground arena that
we've seen in all the footage the
Loudred are being used by DJ's as
loudspeakers to amplify their music the
screens are all displaying battle
prompts from the classic games - like
this says critical hit while you see the
Gengar fighting the Blastoise there's
actually a Magikarp and a fish tank on
the side of the arena here this is the
first cubone I think we've seen these
are a pong they're part of the game's
story - but obviously there's a billion
other Pokemon probably in the background
- some of these shots so let me know if
you spotted any Easter eggs that I
didn't include in the video and let me
know what you think the big twist is of
the movie just posted in the comments
below because the way the end of the
video game was very ambiguous is open to
interpretation but like I said I think
it has something to do with Mewtwo using
his psychic abilities to fuse Tim's
father's mind with this regular Pokemon
to create the personality that is
detective Pikachu that we see during the
course of the movie
speaking of Ryan Reynolds Deadpool there
supposed to be a new x-men Dark Phoenix
trailer posting tomorrow I'll do a video
for that leave all your video requests
in the comments below too while you wait
for everything click here for my
non-spoilery Captain Marvel
review and click here to learn about all
the Marvel movies coming after Avengers
end game during Marvel phase 4 thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight